dejamos kabul
vamos a hacer un vídeo durante la ruta
hacia la frontera pakistán
hay muchos puntos de control talibanes
pero los puntos de control se pasan
bastante fácil
a ello pero se molestaba
los talibanes son como la policía
nos estamos acercando a jalalabad
en jalalabad hay una presencia
importante del estado islámico en
afganistán ser el estado islámico de
corazón es el estado islámico de asia
central y rival de los talibán
así que a la lavada es una frontera
difícil de cruzar
y mi conductor lo sabe
este era un punto muy peligroso muy
peligroso
una vez después muy cerca a nosotros que
el estado islámico disparo a alguien
dentro del auto aquí
hay talibanes en cada punto de control y
en cada punto de control alrededor de
jalalabad
estamos cerca a la frontera paquistaní
ellos toman fotos a las personas jóvenes
para identificarlas y revisan
aleatoriamente automóviles
estamos en la frontera cruzando hacia
pakistán en torkham está controlada por
los talibanes
acabamos de cruzar la frontera
fue tan fácil como yo esperado
hemos estado atrapados en tierra de
nadie por tres horas entre el capitán y
sacristán
este señor lleva seis horas esperando
como esperábamos nada es fácil de
pakistán ha cambiado la ley y es un poco
duro
estamos esperando a pesar de todas las
autorizaciones no podemos pasar
una jornada un poco un poco larga pero
pero me ve
ahora nos encaminamos hacia las zonas
tribales de la frontera
afgano-paquistaní
son conocidas como el jíber paz con otro
contacto que me está llevando a
islamabad
después de esperar seis horas podemos
sentir por lo que están pasando
todos los refugiados para pasar una
frontera que ellos quieren cruzar
es algo para meditar